[موسيقى]
دعنا نذهب على
ما يرام ، لذا فهناك أه
المراسلين يصرخون أسئلة ولكن أه
رأينا مصافحة مصافحة كبيرة جدًا
كلاريسا من
هذين الزعيمين الرئيس الروسي
الرئيس الأمريكي أه البيان الافتتاحي
من
الرئيس السويسري ترجم إلى الروسية
و  ثم بالإنجليزية ،
نعم ، مرحبًا بك في مدينة السلام ، كما قال
، وأتمنى محادثات مثمرة ليس
فقط لبلدانك
ولكن للعالم بأسره وأعتقد
أن هذا جزء مما يجب
تذكره هنا
عندما ننظر إلى القمة
عندما ننظر  إن الأهمية التاريخية
المحتملة لا تتعلق فقط بجلوس الولايات المتحدة وروسيا
لإجراء محادثة ، بل
تتعلق بالديمقراطيات
التي تتحدىها الأنظمة الاستبدادية ، وستتطلع العديد من
البلدان في جميع أنحاء العالم
لمعرفة
ما سيحدث اليوم ما إذا كان يمكن إخراج أي شيء
منه وتحويله  في شيء أكثر
إنتاجية ، تعلم أن
هذه اللحظات تدور حول لحظات
وسأخبرك لحظة واحدة لاحظتها
هناك  تفاعل
بايدن بوتين ، بدا المصافحة بيدن في العين
بابتسامة نظر بوتين بعيدًا
مرة أخرى ، لا تريد أن تقرأ كثيرًا أو
قليلًا جدًا ، ولكن مرة أخرى هذه تتعلق
بالمواقف العامة ، إنها تتعلق
بكيفية عرض القوة وكان ذلك أمرًا
بارزًا  لحظة بالنسبة لي كما شاهدت